Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
MY WIFE THOUGHT I WAS CRAZY,
BUT MY DOG DIDN'T.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
♪ BALM CHICKY BALM BALM ♪
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
BALM CHICKY BALM BALM!
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
YOU KNOW,
IT'S GOOD TO BE RUTHLESS
AND MEAN IN BUSINESS.
YES, IT IS. YES, IT IS.
BUT I'VE FOUND THAT IT'S ALSO
VERY GOOD TO BE NICE.
IF YOU WANT THE DISCOUNT
PILOT FISH, TAKE THE DEAL.
I'M NOT A PILOT FISH,
GOSH DARN IT!
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
AND WHO ACTUALLY CARES?
I'D LIKE TO HEAR
THAT ANSWER, TOO.
I'M NOT SURE WHY THEY CALL YOU
MR. WONDERFUL.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
MY NAME IS ANDREW FELD.
I LIVE IN DAVENPORT, FLORIDA,
WITH MY BEAUTIFUL WIFE, CORRINA,
MY DAUGHTER, CLAUDIA,
AND OUR DOG, CHLOE,
AND I AM THE OWNER
OF FRESH PATCH.
CORRINA AND I GOT MARRIED
THREE MONTHS
AFTER MEETING EACH OTHER,
AND THEN CORRINA GOT OFFERED
A JOB IN FLORIDA,
SO WE DECIDED
THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
TO START SOMETHING NEW.
WE MOVED FROM A HOUSE
WITH A BACKYARD
INTO A CONDO
WITH A SMALL BALCONY.
IT WAS REALLY HARD
ON MY DOG, CHLOE.
I DIDN'T HAVE A JOB.
I WAS APPLYING FOR JOBS,
AND NOTHING WAS HAPPENING.
AND THEN I FOUND OUT
MY WIFE WAS PREGNANT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I KNEW I NEEDED TO STEP UP
AND FIND A WAY
TO PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY.
I CAME UP WITH AN INVENTION
FOR CHLOE
THAT SHE TOOK TO REALLY WELL,
SO I DECIDED TO TURN THAT IDEA
INTO A BUSINESS.
FINANCIALLY, I'M ALL IN.
I NEED THE SHARKS' EXPERTISE
AS MUCH AS THEIR CAPITAL
IF I'M GONNA BE
ABLE TO PULL THIS OFF.
MY FAMILY'S FUTURE
DEPENDS ON THIS BUSINESS,
SO IF I DON'T GET A DEAL --
WELL, THAT'S NOT AN OPTION.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HI.
MY NAME IS ANDREW FELD.
I LIVE IN DAVENPORT, FLORIDA,
AND I'M THE FOUNDER
OF FRESH PATCH.
I'M SEEKING $150,000
FOR A 10% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
FRESH PATCH
IS A REAL-GRASS DELIVERY SERVICE
FOR THE MILLION PETS
WHO HAVE EVERYTHING
EXCEPT THEIR OWN BACKYARD.
FOUR YEARS AGO,
MY WIFE AND I AND MY DOG, CHLOE,
MOVED FROM A HOUSE
WITH A BACKYARD INTO A CONDO.
NOW, FOR A DOG,
THERE'S NOTHING WORSE
THAN NOT HAVING
YOUR OWN BACKYARD.
I WAS BUSY BUILDING
AND MAINTAINING
A MINI-BACKYARD ON MY BALCONY.
MY WIFE THOUGHT I WAS CRAZY,
BUT MY DOG DIDN'T.
[ LAUGHS ]
MY DOG ABSOLUTELY LOVED
THAT GRASSY AREA I HAD CREATED.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WAS THE GRASS
WOULD EVENTUALLY DIE OFF,
AND MAINTAINING IT
BECAME A CHORE.
AND THAT IS WHERE THE IDEA
FOR FRESH PATCH WAS BORN.
WE ARE THE FIRST REAL-GRASS
DELIVERY SERVICE OF ITS KIND,
SHIPPING OUR BOXES
OF HYDROPONICALLY GROWN GRASS
TO OUR SUBSCRIBERS
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THERE'S NO CLEANING.
THERE'S NO MESS.
WHEN A NEW FRESH PATCH
ARRIVES ON YOUR DOORSTEP,
YOU SIMPLY THROW
THE OLD ONE AWAY.
WE'RE A HIT
WITH ALL KINDS OF CUSTOMERS
WHO USE IT WITH
ALL DIFFERENT KINDS OF PETS.
IT'S EASY, IT'S CONVENIENT,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
THE ANIMALS LOVE IT.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S INTERESTED
IN TURNING
SOME OF THIS GREEN GRASS
INTO GREEN CASH?
ANDREW,
YOU HAD IT ON YOUR BALCONY.
I DID.
WHAT IF I BRING IT
INTO MY APARTMENT,
IN AN ENCLOSED
ENVIRONMENT?
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE
BEFORE IT HAS AN ODOR?
IT'S A LIVING PLANT,
SO IT NATURALLY
BREAKS DOWN ODORS.
IT DOESN'T SMELL.
Greiner:
THERE ARE, LIKE,
LITTLE PAPER THINGS
THAT YOU CAN LAY DOWN...
BUT DOGS
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE, RIGHT?
...THAT SMALL DOGS
ARE TRAINED TO GO ON.
RIGHT. PEE PADS. AND EVERYONE
KNOWS WHAT PEE PADS --
PEE PADS.
BUT NO ONE LIKES PEE PADS.
PETS DON'T LIKE PEE PADS.
DOGS DON'T LIKE PEE PADS.
THEY TEAR THEM UP.
THEY'RE CONFUSING TO USE.
THIS IS INSTINCTIVE
TO DOGS.
THERE'S NO TRAINING
INVOLVED.
WHAT IF I HAVE
A REALLY BIG DOG?
LET ME SHOW YOU
THE FRESH PATCH XL.
THIS IS
THIS IS FOR
A LARGER-SIZED DOG.
OH, I SEE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
I'VE SOLD OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF THIS TO DATE.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING.
GOOD FOR YOU. GOOD FOR YOU.
THAT'S AWESOME.
ANDREW,
THAT'S AMAZING.
IS THAT ALL ONLINE SALES,
OR DO YOU SELL IN ANY OTHER WAY?
IT'S ALL ONLINE.
WE'RE DIRECT TO THE CUSTOMER.
THAT'S EVEN BETTER.
SO, ANDREW,
YOU MUST HAVE
A RECURRING-REVENUE MODEL,
OBVIOUSLY.
YES, WE OFFER SEVERAL DIFFERENT
SUBSCRIPTION MODELS.
THE MOST COMMON ONE
IS EVERY OTHER WEEK.
WHAT DOES IT COST?
$25 PER DELIVERY.
HOW MANY RECURRING CUSTOMERS
DO YOU HAVE --
SUBSCRIBERS
DO YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW?
OKAY, ON-THE-BOOK SUBSCRIBERS --
LIKE 550.
OKAY.
O'Leary:
WHAT'S YOUR ATTRITION RATE?
HOW MANY PEOPLE TRY IT ONCE
AND NEVER USE IT AGAIN?
I WOULD SAY 25%
WILL STICK WITH IT.
ANDREW,
TWO OUT OF THREE CUSTOMERS
WHO ORDER FROM YOU
DON'T ORDER AGAIN?
CORRECT.
THAT'S A BIG NUMBER.
YEAH, THAT CONCERNED ME,
TOO, BARBARA.
SO, YOU'RE ONLY ONLINE
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT?
CORRECT.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU TO PUT
TOGETHER AND SHIP EVERYTHING?
THESE BOXES OF GRASS COME IN
JUST UNDER $5, INCLUDING LABOR.
THEN THE SHIPPING --
ON THE WEST COAST,
YOU'RE LOOKING AT $7 TO $8.
WHEN WE'RE SHIPPING THESE
TO NEW YORK,
YOU'RE LOOKING AT $14, $15.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU USE
A SHIP STATION IN ORDER TO --
WHO PAYS THE SHIPPING?
I DO.
SO, THAT'S WHAT'S KILLED
YOUR MARGINS.
'CAUSE IT COULD BE $19
ON A $25 SALE PRICE, RIGHT?
RIGHT.
AND WHO'S DOING
ALL THE TECHNOLOGY FOR YOU?
THAT'S ME. I CAME UP
WITH THE IDEA FOR THIS
THE DAY AFTER I FOUND OUT
MY WIFE WAS PREGNANT.
THAT'LL MAKE YOU
GO TO WORK.
IT'S CRAZY.
SO IT WAS LIKE
AN INSPIRATION FOR IT.
I LEARNED HOW TO BUILD
A WEBSITE.
I DID THE TRADEMARK.
YOU KNOW, I DO CUSTOMER SERVICE.
SO IT'S BEEN ALL
DO-IT-YOURSELF SO FAR.
YEAH, I'M DOING EVERYTHING.
ANDREW, I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THE 75% ATTRITION RATE.
I WORRY THAT IT'S MORE
OF A NOVELTY RIGHT NOW.
BUT, MAN,
YOU'VE GOT SOME GREAT SALES.
I...
I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST DON'T SEE
MY DOG USING IT.
I'D BE HAPPY
TO SEND YOU A FREE ONE
AND SEE
HOW HE TAKES TO IT.
SEND ME A NEW DOG.
IT'LL BE CHEAPER.
[ Laughing ] OKAY.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
SO, WHERE DO YOU HYDROPONICALLY
GROW YOUR GRASS PATCHES?
THEY'RE SOURCED
FROM CALIFORNIA.
AND THE REASON
I'M HERE TODAY IS
TWO THIRDS OF THE MONEY
I'M ASKING FOR
IS GONNA GO
TOWARDS BUILDING OUT
OUR EAST COAST
DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
O'Leary: SO, ANDY,
NOW WE HAVE TO FACE REALITY.
THERE'S NOTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THERE IS SOMETHING PROPRIETARY.
I HAVE A PATENT.
WHAT'S THE PATENT?
IT'S FOR A PORTABLE
AND DISPOSABLE
LIVING PATCH OF GRASS.
THERE'S A PATENT FOR THAT?
I HAVE IT.
DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMPETITION?
PEE PAD'S
AND SYNTHETIC GRASS,
AND WE DO HAVE A COMPANY THAT
IS INFRINGING ON OUR PATENT.
ARE -- ARE YOU
GONNA GO AFTER THEM?
I'M SUING THEM.
I'M MORE INTERESTED NOW
THAT THERE'S SOMEBODY I CAN SUE.
Cuban:
NO KIDDING, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU KNOW,
THAT'S INTERESTING.
BECAUSE AT SOME POINT,
UM, IF YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL,
YOU CAN GET THEIR CUSTOMERS
AS PART OF THE SETTLEMENT.
EXACTLY.
LET ME MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
BECAUSE I LIKE IT.
I JUST THINK IT'S SO SIMPLE,
AND IT COULD GROW,
AND THERE'S A LOT I COULD DO
TO HELP YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000
FOR 33 1/3%.
JUST A STRAIGHT OFFER?
STRAIGHT UP, STRAIGHT UP.
DAMN.
I REALLY THINK
THIS COMPANY IS WORTH --
I KNOW THIS COMPANY
IS WORTH SO MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
WELL, DO YOU HAVE
ANY FLEXIBILITY
ON THE EQUITY
YOU'RE WILLING TO PART WITH?
I REALLY DON'T.
I WANTED TO COME IN HERE
AND GIVE YOU GUYS
A GOOD VALUATION
ON THIS COMPANY.
10% IS NOT A LOT.
10% IS NOT A LOT, ANDREW.
IT'S TOO EARLY FOR YOU
TO GIVE ANYONE A COUNTEROFFER.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
THE OFFERS.
THAT'S TRUE.
THANK YOU, BARBARA.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER --
$150,000 FOR 20%,
BUT THERE'S ONE CONTINGENCY.
YOU HAVE TO COMMIT TO BRINGING
THIS INTO THE PET SHOPS.
YOU WANT TO GO
TO RETAIL?
DEFINITELY.
I KNOW THE PET SPACE
INSIDE AND OUT
BECAUSE I BOUGHT A BUSINESS
NAMED RYAN'S BARKERY,
AND I HAD TO BUILD ALL THOSE
BRIDGES INTO THOSE STORES.
BUT I KNOW ALL THOSE PEOPLE.
I HAVE SUCH GREAT RELATIONSHIPS.
I THINK THEY WOULD CLEARLY
ORDER THIS PRODUCT AND SELL IT.
SO I'LL GIVE YOU
THE MONEY YOU'RE ASKING FOR,
BUT I MUST HAVE 20%,
AND YOU MUST COMMIT
TO BRINGING IT INTO RETAIL.
I'M GONNA DROP MY ASK ON EQUITY
DOWN TO 20%
AND REMOVE THAT COVENANT
REGARDING RETAIL.
'CAUSE IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME
THAT THAT'S A GOOD STRATEGY.
IT'S PERISHABLE.
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
DO YOU KNOW WHY EVERYBODY'S
GONNA BUY THIS IN A STORE?
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WHO HAS A PET
IN THE CITY FEELS GUILTY.
IF THEY COULD BRING
A NICE SLAB OF GREEN GRASS
HOME TO THE DOG
THEY'RE IGNORING
AND NOT EVER TAKING
TO THE PARK,
THEY'RE GONNA FEEL SO GOOD.
IT'S A FEEL-GOOD PRODUCT
MORE THAN IT IS
A PRODUCTIVE PRODUCT
FOR HELPING THE DOG.
CORRECT.
I KNOW THE HUGE VALUE
OF THIS,
AND I THINK YOU'RE JUST
AT THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
I REALLY AM.
'CAUSE GOING
INTO THE EAST COAST,
I THINK THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
REALLY GONNA RAMP UP HUGE
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE TO
WALK THEIR DOGS IN THE WINTER.
I LIKE THAT YOU PRICED IT
AT A GOOD PRICE.
SO I'M THINKING
ABOUT THIS.
YOU CAME IN WANTING
$150,000 FOR 10%?
CORRECT.
I'M THINKING
FOR A MINUTE.
I'M GONNA WAIT TO HEAR
WHAT MARK SAYS.
OKAY.
YOU'RE SITTING BACK,
WAITING IN THE WINGS.
I ALWAYS DO.
SO, HERE'S WHAT I SEE.
I AGREE WITH BARBARA
THAT IT IS A RETAIL PLAY
IN MAJOR VERTICAL CITIES.
BUT I ALSO SEE IT
AS A TECH PLAY,
WHICH IS
THE MOST INTERESTING TO ME.
SO YOU'RE LEAVING
A TON OF MONEY ON THE TABLE,
AND YOU KNOW IT, RIGHT?
I AGREE.
SO, I WANT TO PARTNER
WITH BARBARA ON THIS.
I ALREADY SAID YES.
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
OVER THE YEARS
IS THAT WE EACH HAVE
OUR OWN SKILL SETS.
SO, TECHNOLOGY
TENDS TO BE MINE,
AND BARBARA DOES A GREAT JOB
AT RETAIL,
PARTICULARLY
WITHIN NEW YORK CITY.
WHAT WE DO IS,
WE'LL TAKE OVER YOUR ACCOUNTING.
WE'LL TAKE OVER YOUR WEBSITE
AND ACCELERATE YOUR GROWTH
SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO DEAL
WITH ANY OF THAT.
YOU CAN FOCUS
ON WHAT YOU DO.
Herjavec: MAN, THIS IS GONNA BE
AN AWFUL OFFER.
HE'S REALLY SELLING.
WHAT I'M GONNA SAY IS --
SO WHAT IS THE DEAL?
YEAH, WHAT'S THE DEAL?
THE DEAL IS THE SAME
AS WHAT BARBARA OFFERED.
$150,000 FOR 20%,
AND YOU GET TWO SHARKS,
BUT YOU GOT TO DECIDE
RIGHT NOW.
LORI STILL HASN'T
MADE AN OFFER, ANDREW.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
WOULD YOU GUYS BE WILLING
TO WORK ON EQUITY?
I'LL TAKE THE OFFER.
THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S A SMART MAN.
[ LAUGHS ]
Corcoran: GREAT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT
A LOT BIGGER.
IT'LL WORK OUT
REALLY WELL.
TERRIFIC.
YOU'RE SO SMART.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHOO-HOO!
Feld:
I WENT WITH MARK AND BARBARA
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE BEST TWO
TO HELP ME MAKE
THE IMPORTANT DECISIONS I NEED
WITH THIS COMPANY,
WITH THE WEBSITE
AND THE BRANDING
AND JUST GROWING IT
TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK ARE FRIENDS
WITH A NEW TWIST ON LIP BALM.
HI. I'M LIZ MOSKOW.
AND I'M ABBY SCHWALB.
LIZ AND I ARE CO-FOUNDERS
OF BALM CHICKY BALM BALM.
WE'RE HERE TODAY SEEKING
A $75,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 20%
EQUITY STAKE IN OUR COMPANY.
EVERYONE HERE HAS USED
A LIP BALM, RIGHT?
AND FRIENDS,
CO-WORKERS, RELATIVES,
NOT TO MENTION
GERMY CHILDREN,
FIND THE NEED TO BORROW
AND RUN THEIR LIPS
ALL OVER YOUR BALM.
WELL, WE'VE COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM.
INTRODUCING...
♪ BALM CHICKY BALM BALM ♪
A SEXY,
'70s-INSPIRED LIP-BALM BRAND
WITH ONE SPECIAL PACKAGE.
WHAT IS THAT PACKAGE?
IT'S THE FRIEND END TUBE,
DESIGNED TO LET PEOPLE SHARE
THEIR PERSONAL-CARE PRODUCTS
WITHOUT SHARING
ANY NASTY GERMS.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
MY LIPS ARE SO DRY.
CAN I BORROW YOUR BALM?
YOU SURE CAN.
YOU'RE GIVING ME
THE FRIEND END?
WELL, I DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU'VE BEEN.
THIS IS SO TRUE.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THE FRIEND END PROVIDES
A SEPARATE POT OF BALM
ON THE FLIP SIDE.
THIS ALLOWS ITS OWNER TO BE
GENEROUS WITH THEIR LIP BALM
WHILE KEEPING THEIR SIDE
PRISTINE AND CLEAN,
GERM-FREE
FOR THEIR OWN PERSONAL USE.
THUS TRANSFORMING AN ORDINARY,
EVERYDAY-USE PRODUCT
LIKE LIP BALM
INTO A SHARABLE AND SPREADABLE
CONVERSATION PIECE.
WHO'S HOT TO TROT
AND READY TO BECOME
GREAT BEDFELLOWS
WITH
BALM CHICKY BALM BALM?
Corcoran:
SO, LISTEN, ABBY,
HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE --
WHO WOULD EVEN THINK OF IT?
[ CHUCKLES ] RIGHT?
WELL, THAT'S PROBABLY
WHAT WE DO BEST
IS THINK OF VERY STRANGE IDEAS
AND SORT OF PURSUE THEM.
AND WHO ACTUALLY CARES?
I'D LIKE TO HEAR
THAT ANSWER, TOO.
HOW DID YOU THINK OF IT?
KEVIN!
WELL, UM,
WE'RE BOTH BALM FREAKS.
WE LIKE TO USE LIP BALM.
WE LIVE IN THE MOUNTAINS.
WE SKI,
AND OFTEN WE FIND
THAT ANYTIME YOU PULL OUT
A LIP BALM, LIKE YAWNING,
LIP-BALM BORROWING
IS RAMPANT.
DO WE GET TO SEE IT?
YES, ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND CAN YOU TELL US
IF YOU'RE ACTUALLY SELLING ANY?
THAT WOULD PROVE THAT MAYBE
PEOPLE CARE ABOUT THIS IDEA.
WE'RE CURRENTLY
IN OVER 60 STORES
IN BOTH THE U.K., CANADA,
AND THE U.S.
Greiner: THANK YOU.
HEY, LORI,
CAN I BORROW YOUR BALM?
SURE, ROBERT.
HERE'S MY FRIEND END.
Cuban:
CAN I JUST ASK --
ARE THE RETAIL STORES,
UM, ADULT NOVELTY STORES?
YES AND NO.
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION, MARK.
THERE'S NOTHING WITH THAT.
BUT, I MEAN, ALL THE PACKAGING.
I MEAN...
WE'D LOVE TO TELL YOU MORE
ABOUT THAT.
I BET YOU WOULD,
SO GO AHEAD.
YES, WE WOULD.
WE CAME UP WITH THIS
BALM CHICKY BALM BALM LABEL
AS A PROOF-OF-CONCEPT IDEA
FOR THE FRIEND END.
SO THEN, WHAT WE DECIDED WAS
THAT WE WANT TO GO AFTER MASS.
WE THINK THAT IT HAS
VARIOUS LICENSING OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE OUR PATENT
NOT ONLY COVERS THIS SHAPE TUBE,
IT COVERS ANY SHAPE TUBE
THAT'S COMPRISED
OF A LIFT DEVICE --
EITHER A TWIST, A PUSH-UP,
OR A LIFT --
WITH A STATIONARY POT
ON THE BOTTOM.
Herjavec: LOVE THE NAME.
HOW MANY ARE YOU SELLING TODAY,
IF YOU'RE SELLING ANY?
WE'VE SOLD, UM,
$17,000 WORTH OF BALM.
SORRY. $17,000?
DOLLARS.
O'Leary: IS THAT ENOUGH
TO KEEP IT IN RETAIL?
'CAUSE YOU SAID
YOU HAD 60 STORES.
YES.
YOU'RE SELLING
.00-NOTHING-BURGER PER STORE.
THE FACTS ARE
WE CREATED IT
JUST TO GET
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN RUNNING.
WE HAVE A MOLD,
WE HAVE THE PATENT ON THE TUBE,
AND SO WE WANTED TO SEE
IF WE CAN GET INTO STORES
WITH NO MONEY
PUT TOWARDS MARKETING.
$17,000 IN SALES IN THIS MARKET,
IT'S DEPRESSING.
WHAT DOES IT SELL FOR?
THIS IS $4.50 WHOLESALE
AND $9.50 RETAIL
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT IS THE PRICE
OF AN AVERAGE LIP BALM?
A REGULAR SIZE --
EVEN THOUGH --
EVEN THOUGH
IT'S SMALLER THAN THIS,
A REGULAR SIZE,
WHAT DOES IT COST?
THE AVERAGE COST OF
A VERY SMALL LIP BALM IS $2.59.
SO FOR $2.59,
THEY COULD TECHNICALLY
BUY THREE
FOR LESS MONEY THAN YOUR ONE.
Moskow: RIGHT. BUT IT'S NOT
A CONVERSATION PIECE.
UH-OH.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THEY WANT TO SHARE.
Cuban:
YEAH, BUT PEOPLE DON'T GIVE
THAT MUCH THOUGHT
TO THEIR LIP-BALM PURCHASING.
GUYS, LOOK,
HERE-- HERE'S WHAT I SEE.
YOU GUYS HAVE GOT A PRODUCT,
NOT A COMPANY YET,
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO TURN IT INTO A COMPANY.
AND THAT'S ALWAYS HARD.
BUT WHAT YOU DO HAVE ALSO
IS A NICHE.
SELLING THESE
IN ADULT-ENTERTAINMENT LOCATIONS
IS GREAT.
RUN WITH THAT.
MAKE SOME MONEY OFF OF IT.
WIN THE BATTLE YOU'RE IN
BEFORE TRYING TO TURN THIS
INTO A REAL COMPANY.
WE'VE SPOKEN
TO INDUSTRY EXPERTS
ABOUT THE NAME
BALM CHICKY BALM BALM,
AND THEY HAVE SAID
BALM CHICKY BALM BALM IS GOLD.
I-IT'S NOT GOLD,IT'S CUTE,
AND THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
YOU HAVE A FANTASTIC,
CATCHY NAME.
BUT REALLY
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
IS HAVING THE GREAT PRODUCT.
BECAUSE THEN YOU CAN
THINK OF A GREAT NAME.
DID YOU TRY THE PRODUCT?
I DID TRY IT.
I TRIED THE FRIEND END,
WHERE I HAD TO GO IN,
WITH MY FINGER,
AND I DIDN'T LIKE THAT.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec:
LADIES, I --
A COUPLE
OF CHALLENGES.
MOST BUYERS ARE YOUNGER-SKEWED,
LIKE KIDS, TEENAGERS, AND SO ON.
I'M NOT SURE
I WANT MY KIDS
BUYING SOMETHING
WITH AN ADULT THEME
IN A GENERAL MARKET.
FOR A NICHE MARKET,
THAT'S FANTASTIC
IF YOU'RE GONNA SELL IT
IN ADULT STORES.
BUT WE CAN ALSO PUT,
VERY EASILY, A LABEL ON HERE
THAT IT IS INTENDED
FOR THOSE PEOPLE,
AND IT HAS THE FRIEND END,
WHICH IS GREAT FOR TEENAGERS.
BUT YOU KNOW, ABBY,
THAT'S REALLY MY CHALLENGE.
EVERY TIME WE GAVE YOU
AN OBJECTION, YOU SAID,
"WE CAN DO THAT, TOO."
WE'RE FLEXIBLE.
WE CAN.
WE CAN DO IT ALL.
IT'S GREAT TO PIVOT,
BUT YOU CAN'T PIVOT
EVERY SINGLE MINUTE.
AND $17,000
IS NOT A PROOF OF CONCEPT.
I DON'T SEE THE COMPANY.
I JUST SEE
A FUN, HIP, COOL NAME.
I HAVE TO SAY IT
ONE MORE TIME BEFORE I'M OUT --
BALM CHICKY BALM BALM.
I'M OUT.
FAIR ENOUGH.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, I-IF I HAD TO DREAM UP
A BUSINESS PLAN,
GETTING MARKET SHARE
IN THE LIP-BALM SPACE
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE
ON THE TOP OF MY LIST.
YOU'RE
SINGLE-CELL-AMOEBA PLAYERS.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN COCKROACHES.
Herjavec: KEVIN, I'M NOT CLEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
ARE YOU IN,
OR ARE YOU OUT?
I'M SAYING
IT'S A BAD WASTE OF TIME...
I THINK I HAVE A GUESS.
...BOTH YOURS AND MINE.
AND I'M GONNA BURN IT MYSELF
IF YOU DON'T.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANKS.
I THINK
YOU HAVE A CUTE NAME,
BUT I LOVE A PRODUCT
THAT SOLVES A SIMPLE PROBLEM,
AND I DON'T REALLY THINK
THERE'S A PROBLEM OUT THERE
THAT YOU HAVE TO SOLVE
WITH THIS.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU,
I HAVE VERY FEW BUSINESSES
THAT DIDN'T HAVE TO BE
REINVENTED THREE TIMES OVER
BEFORE THEY BECAME
GOOD SELLERS.
DO NOT ENCOURAGE THEM, BARBARA.
I FORBID IT.
NO, I'M GONNA ENCOURAGE YOU.
YOU'RE REINVENTING IT
AS YOU GO,
SEEING WHAT'S WRONG,
MAKING A LITTLE MOVEMENT
TO THE LEFT OR THE RIGHT.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
RIGHT INTO A TRAIN.
I'M SURE YOU'LL FIND
A WAY TO DO IT,
BUT I HAVE TO RELUCTANTLY SAY
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, BARBARA.
I'M NOT SURE WHY THEY CALL YOU
MR. WONDERFUL.
NOW YOU KNOW.
I TELL THE TRUTH.
YOU'VE GOT
A PROFITABLE NICHE
THAT YOU SHOULD BE EXPLOITING --
ADULT ENTERTAINMENT.
EXPLOIT THE NICHE
THAT YOU HAVE SUCCESS AT...
I AGREE.
AND YOU WILL MAKE
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS.
NOT EVERY BUSINESS
IS GOING TO BE
A MILLION-DOLLAR
OR $5 MILLION --
IF YOU GUYS ARE SELLING
$200,000 WORTH OF LIP BALM
AND ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS DROP-SHIP
FROM YOUR MANUFACTURER,
AND YOU'RE PUTTING $100,000
IN YOUR POCKET
WITHOUT DOING ANYTHING...
BUT WHEN YOU TRY TO DO
ALL OF THIS,
YOU ARE GOING TO GROW YOURSELF
OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
WIN THE BATTLES
YOU'RE IN FIRST.
OR KNOW THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO LOSE WITH CERTAINTY
AND DON'T BOTHER
FIGHTING IT.
CAN WE HAVE THAT NOT BE
THE LAST WORD AS WE WALK OUT?
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
YOU KNOW THAT LAST WORD'S
GONNA BE?
BALM CHICKY BALM BALM!
THERE YOU GO.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
THIS IS HORRIBLE.
MR. NOT-SO-WONDERFUL.
[ LAUGHS ]
Moskow: WHAT'S NEXT
FOR BALM CHICKY BALM BALM
IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
INTO MASS SO THAT EVERYONE
FROM GRANNIES TO TODDLERS
WILL BE SAYING...
♪ BALM CHICKY BALM BALM ♪
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
WHO BELIEVES HE HAS A SOLUTION
TO THE PROBLEM
OF CHRONICALLY CLOGGED DRAINS.
MY NAME IS NAUSHAD ALI,
AND I'M FROM WOODINVILLE,
WASHINGTON.
MY PRODUCT IS THE DRAIN STRAIN,
AND I'M HERE TODAY
SEEKING $110,000
FOR A 15% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
SHARKS, IF YOU'RE LIKE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS,
AT ONE POINT OR ANOTHER,
YOU'VE HAD A CLOGGED DRAIN.
AND YOU KNOW
IT IS SUCH A PAIN TO CLEAN.
YOU MIGHT GO HAIR-FISHING
WITH A HANGER
AND TOUCH WET, NASTY
CLUMPS OF HAIR.
THERE'S KEVIN'S HAIR.
DISGUSTING!
OR YOU MIGHT POUR
ENVIRONMENTALLY HARMFUL
DRAIN CLEANERS IN YOUR SINK
AND WAIT PATIENTLY
TO SEE IF IT WORKS.
MY PRODUCT ELIMINATES
EXPENSIVE PLUMBING CALLS,
AND YOU DON'T EVEN
GET YOUR HANDS DIRTY.
YOU NEVER TOUCH THE GUNK!
I'M PROUD TO INTRODUCE
THE REVOLUTIONARY DRAIN STRAIN
WITH TLC TECHNOLOGY.
SIMPLY TURN, LIFT, CLICK --
PROBLEM SOLVED.
NOW ATTACH A REPLACEMENT BASKET
TO THE STOPPER TOP,
INSERT BACK INTO YOUR SINK.
YOU'RE DONE!
SHARKS, IF YOU INVEST
IN MY COMPANY,
I PROMISE TO WORK HARD EVERY DAY
TO MAKE SURE YOUR MONEY
DOESN'T GO DOWN THE DRAIN.
ALL RIGHT, I THINK
PROBABLY THE BEST THING TO DO
IS GIVE YOU SOME SAMPLES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
SO...
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
HERE'S ONE FOR YOU, ROBERT.
HERE.
Greiner: OH, THANK YOU.
ARE THESE PROTOTYPES,
OR IS THIS THE REAL THING?
YEAH, THOSE ARE 3-D --
THOSE ARE 3-D PROTOTYPES,
SO THEY'RE FRAGILE.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
YEAH, YOU BET.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, BASICALLY,
JUST TURN TO THE LEFT, LIFT.
YEAH, SO ONCE YOU LIFT IT OUT,
YOU SQUEEZE, AND IT --
Greiner: I'M CURIOUS.
DOESN'T THIS START
TO CLOG UP THIS
SO THAT YOU WOULD CONSTANTLY
BE HAVING TO CLEAN THIS OUT?
SO, WE HAVE IT IN OUR DRAIN
AT OUR HOME, RIGHT?
FOR HEAVY USE,
YOU -- YOU WOULD EXPECT
TO CHANGE THAT
ONCE EVERY FOUR TO SIX WEEKS.
O'Leary: SO, IN THE HISTORY
OF "SHARK TANK,"
THIS PRODUCT,
ABOVE ANY OTHER,
LENDS ITSELF TO A LICENSING DEAL
WITH MANUFACTURERS.
THE IDEA OF TAKING THIS
AS A PRODUCT ON ITS OWN
INTO RETAIL OR INTO DISTRIBUTION
IS A REALLY STUPID IDEA.
THE ONLY WAY THIS BECOMES
A MULTIMILLION-DOLLAR SUCCESS
IS IF YOU CAN CONVINCE
A MANUFACTURER OF PLUMBING
THAT THIS IS
A BETTER MOUSE TRAP.
ARE YOU
PREPARED TO DO THAT?
ABSOLUTELY. THAT IS DEFINITELY
ONE OF THE LAUNCH STRATEGIES.
WHY AREN'T YOU AT KOHLER
AND THIS IS SIMPLY PART
OF THEIR NEW FAUCET LINE?
UH, I CERTAINLY PLAN TO BE.
IN FACT, I JUST GOT THE FINAL
PRODUCTION-READY DESIGNS
FOUR WEEKS AGO
IN MY HAND, YEAH.
SO THIS HASN'T EVEN BEEN
MANUFACTURED YET.
THESE ARE ALL PROTOTYPES.
THOSE ARE ALL 3-D PROTOTYPES,
BUT I'VE GOT SOURCING COSTS.
YEAH.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
SO, FOR THE LAST 11 YEARS,
I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN A REALTOR.
MY BUSINESS WAS THRIVING,
AND THEN 2008 HIT, RIGHT?
AND THEN THE BOTTOM FELL OUT.
WE LITERALLY LOST EVERYTHING.
WE, UH, HAD OUR HOME
FORECLOSED ON.
WOW.
AND I HAD TWO CHOICES
AT THAT POINT --
I COULD EITHER LAY ON THE MAT
OR FIGHT.
AND I WASN'T GONNA LET
MY CHILDREN SEE ME ON THE MAT.
AND I WAS NOT GONNA
LET THAT BE MY LEGACY.
SO I REFOCUSED,
GOT BACK ON MY FEET,
BACK IN REAL ESTATE,
AND LAST YEAR,
I'M PROUD TO SAY,
I WAS THE NUMBER 10
FULL-SERVICE REALTOR
IN THE ENTIRE STATE
OF WASHINGTON.
THAT'S NOT EASY TO DO.
GOOD FOR YOU.
WHAT DO YOU NEED FROM US?
OBVIOUSLY,
I NEED YOUR EXPERIENCE.
I'M GOING TO GUESS
THAT WHEN YOU CALL THE C.E.O.
OF YOUR FAVORITE
PLUMBING COMPANY,
HE DOESN'T RETURN
YOUR CALL.
I DON'T HAVE THAT PROBLEM.
EXACTLY.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
YOUR $110,000 FOR 20%.
BUT IT'S CONTINGENT
ON SIGNING A LICENSING DEAL
WITH A MANUFACTURER
OF YOUR CHOICE,
UNDER TERMS
OF YOUR CHOICE.
I'M GONNA NEGOTIATE THEM.
I SEE THE PATH TO MAKING
A LOT OF MONEY WITH THIS,
AND THERE'S ONLY ONE PATH.
YEAH.
YOU KNOW,
YOU MAY FIND ANOTHER SHARK.
LORI MAY WANT TO SIT ON QVC
WITH A SINK AND SOME GLOVES ON
AND WHATEVER ELSE,
BUT I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT
ON IT?
BAM!
NOBODY ELSE CAN DO THIS.
SO YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL.
THE QUESTION IS,
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE MY OFFER,
OR DO YOU WANT TO WAIT
ALL DAY
FOR THE REST
OF THESE SHARKETTES?
WELL, I'D LIKE TO GIVE THE OTHER
SHARKS AN OPPORTUNITY TO --
WELL, I'LL --
I'LL SIMPLIFY THINGS, GUYS.
IT'S A PROOF OF CONCEPT,
RIGHT, THAT YOU REALLY
HAVEN'T PROVEN YET.
IT'S A PRODUCT.
IT'S NOT A COMPANY.
IT'S NOT YOUR PRIMARY FOCUS.
MARK...
DON'T GO OUT.
THERE'S OTHER -- I MEAN,
THERE'S A BATHTUB VERSION
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON.
IT'S NOT JUST A PRODUCT.
THE MOST DIFFICULT
ENTREPRENEURS TO WORK WITH
ARE INVENTORS
BECAUSE THEY'RE FOCUSED
ON INVENTING,
AS OPPOSED TO RUNNING
COMPANIES.
THAT'S WHY I'M NOT PURSUING
ANYTHING ELSE
UNTIL I GET THIS THING --
YOU'VE GOT A --
Y-YOU'RE THE NUMBER 10 REALTOR
IN THE STATE OF WASHINGTON.
MM-HMM.
WHAT'S WRONG
WITH WORKING HARD?
LOOK, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I'M SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
IF THIS GOT TO THAT POINT
WHERE IT REQUIRED
YOUR FULL-TIME USE,
I'M JUST MAKING THE ASSUMPTION
YOU WOULD DO IT FULL TIME.
YEAH.
THIS IS 100% MY PASSION.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
THAT PATH.
RIGHT.
IF YOU DECIDE --
BECAUSE YOU CONTROL IT --
THAT YOU TAKE
THE LICENSE DEAL,
ALL OF THAT IS TAKEN AWAY
FROM YOU, AND YOU CAN GO BACK
TO REINVENTING
THE NEXT GREAT THING.
THAT'S THE OTHER PART
I REALLY LIKE.
I THINK,
UNDER A DEAL LIKE KEVIN,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
YOU KNOW, UH,
WE HAD JEFF FOXWORTHY
ON THE SHOW MANY SEASONS AGO.
HE CALLED IT, UH,
MAILBOX MONEY.
RIGHT.
YOU GET THE CHECK EVERY MONTH.
YEAH, YOU JUST GO
TO THE MAILBOX,
AND YOU GET A CHECK
FROM THE ROYALTY.
YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
YEAH.
ARE YOU SOLD
ON THAT BEING THE RIGHT PATH?
I DON'T WANT TO GO ON
AN ALL-OR-NOTHING DEAL.
HOW LONG WOULD IT TAKE YOU
TO HAVE THIS PRODUCT?
TO HAVE THE PRODUCT?
90 DAYS.
DO YOU HAVE THE CASH
TO FUND THAT --
THE TOOLING
AND THE MANUFACTURING?
THAT'S PART OF WHAT
THE MONEY IS FOR.
SO THAT'S WHAT YOU'D USE
THE MONEY FOR.
I DON'T WANT TO GO
PRODUCE SOMETHING
UNTIL WE'VE GOT DEALS,
RIGHT?
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK KEVIN'S DEAL
IS THE RIGHT DEAL FOR YOU.
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA BE NUTS
SELLING THIS
AS AN INDIVIDUAL PRODUCT.
I'M OUT.
SORRY TO HEAR THAT,
BUT THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S CLEVER.
BUT IT JUST SEEMS
VERY COMPLICATED TO ME.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TESTING
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE FIRST THINGS,
NATURALLY, WHAT YOU WOULD DO.
BUT I'M NOT SURE
THAT THIS IS GONNA WORK.
AND I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
THE PROOF HERE OF THAT.
I THINK IT'S TRICKY,
SO FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
WELL, THANK YOU.
Herjavec:
I LIKE THE PRODUCT.
I THINK THE LARGE
FAUCET MANUFACTURERS
ARE EITHER GONNA ADOPT IT
OR THEY'RE NOT.
AND IF THEY DO ADOPT IT,
YOU CAN DO MULTIPLE
LICENSING DEALS.
KEVIN IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
EVERYBODY RETURNS
HIS PHONE CALL.
THE PROBLEM IS, NOBODY EVER
TALKS TO KEVIN A SECOND TIME.
YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S GOOD
TO BE RUTHLESS
AND -- AND NASTY
AND MEAN IN BUSINESS.
YES, IT IS. YES, IT IS.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
OVER THE LONG TERM,
I'VE FOUND THAT IT'S ALSO
VERY GOOD TO BE NICE.
AND IT'S GOOD TO DO DEALS
WHERE BOTH SIDES MAKE MONEY.
I LIKE THE STRUCTURE --
$110,000.
BUT TO TAKE 20% FROM YOU
FOR, REALLY, MAKING A PHONE CALL
JUST DOESN'T SEEM
FAIR TO ME.
ALL RIGHT.
SO...
HERE'S MY OFFER.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN HAS MADE AN OFFER
OF $110,000 FOR A 20% STAKE,
CONTINGENT ON SECURING
A LICENSING DEAL
FOR NAUSHAD'S
DRAIN-CLOG SOLUTION,
DRAIN STRAIN.
BUT ROBERT IS ALSO INTERESTED.
Herjavec: TO TAKE 20% FROM YOU
FOR, REALLY, MAKING A PHONE CALL
JUST DOESN'T SEEM
FAIR TO ME.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $110,000.
I THINK YOUR ASK FOR 15%
WAS TOO HIGH.
I'M WILLING TO TAKE 10%.
SO I'LL GIVE YOU $110,000,
SAME CONTINGENCY AS KEVIN,
BUT I WANT 10%.
BEFORE YOU MAKE YOUR DECISION,
I WANT TO TELL YOU A STORY.
ALL SHARKS WILL LEARN,
ALL RIGHT?
WE'RE GOING BACK
TO THE ANCIENT TIMES.
APOLLO, A VERY POWERFUL GOD,
WAS DATING A NYMPH.
LOVED HER,
ALL RIGHT?
BUT SO WAS THE FISHERMAN
POMPILUS
INTERESTED IN THE NYMPH.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND HE CONVINCED HER
TO RUN AWAY FROM APOLLO.
BIG MISTAKE.
HERE'S WHY.
WHAT HAPPENS IS APOLLO DAMNED
THE FISHERMAN TO ETERNITY
TO COME BACK FOREVER
AS A PILOT FISH,
DEPENDENT
ON A GREAT WHITE SHARK.
PILOT FISH ONLY EXISTS
OFF THE SCRAPS...
YOU NEED A CHART
FOR THIS ONE.
...THAT ARE INSIDE THE MOUTH
OF THE SHARK
IN A FEEDING FRENZY.
THAT'S DISGUSTING.
THE POINT I'M MAKING IS...
THERE IS A POINT?
...I'M WORTH 10% MORE
BECAUSE I JUST AM.
IF YOU WANT
THE DISCOUNT PILOT FISH,
TAKE THE DEAL, ALL RIGHT?
BUT YOU TO DECIDE, THOUGH.
YOU GOT TO DECIDE.
AND KNOW WITH CERTAINTY
THAT HE'LL ALWAYS BE DEPENDENT
ON THE BIG SHARK.
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
KEVIN,
I APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER.
BUT I THINK THE SHARKS,
EVEN THE PILOT FISH
THAT YOU CALL -- [ LAUGHS ]
I'M NOT A PILOT FISH,
GOSH DARN IT!
ACTUALLY, CAN I -- CAN I
JUST TALK TO MY WIFE REAL QUICK?
WHAT?!
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO TALK
TO YOUR WIFE? WHY WOULD YOU --
NO.
NO WAY, NAUSHAD.
NO. NO.
YOU CAN MAKE THAT DECISION.
THIS IS YOUR MOMENT.
DON'T BLOW IT BY STALLING,
PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT.
ROBERT,
I'D LOVE TO DO A DEAL WITH YOU.
DONE.
HE TOOK THE PILOT FISH.
TAKE THAT, BIG SHOT.
WELL, YOU KNOW --
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS, ROBERT?
I THINK, UH, YOU HAVE A GREAT
PHILOSOPHY, MY WIFE LOVES YOU,
AND I THINK YOU'D BE
A GOOD PERSON TO WORK WITH.
I AM A GOOD PERSON TO WORK WITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TAKE CARE, YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Herjavec: KEVIN.
YES, LITTLE PILOT?
LET'S GO BACK TO THAT STORY.
HOW DOES THE STORY END NOW?
AH, LIVE AND LEARN.
FOR MY FAMILY,
THIS IS A WONDERFUL,
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE FOR MY CHILDREN
TO SEE THAT WE CAN BOUNCE BACK
OFF THE MAT
AND MAKE OUR DREAMS COME TRUE
IS THE LEGACY I WANT TO LEAVE
FOR THEM.
Narrator: IN SEASON FOUR,
COREY WARD AND TREW QUACKENBUSH
MADE A DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN
FOR THEIR GRILLED-CHEESE
FRANCHISE, TOM+CHEE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
I'D SAY WE TAKE THE DEAL.
Narrator:
LET'S SEE HOW THEY'RE DOING NOW.
I, JOHN CRANLEY,
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF CINCINNATI,
DO HEREBY PROCLAIM TOM+CHEE DAY
HERE IN THE CITY OF CINCINNATI.
[ CHEERS ]
Ward: BECAUSE OF OUR
ECONOMIC IMPACT ON THE CITY,
THE MAYOR HAS DECLARED IT
TOM+CHEE DAY.
IN THE YEAR LEADING UP
TO "SHARK TANK,"
WE'D DONE A MILLION DOLLARS
IN SALES.
IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS NOW,
AND WE'VE GROSSED
OVER $14 MILLION.
LET'S GIVE THAT ONE
A TASTE FIRST.
Corcoran: COREY AND TREW
ARE GREAT RESTAURATEURS,
GREAT MARKETERS,
AND THEY'VE WORKED
THEIR BUTTS OFF.
FIVE YEARS AGO,
THEY'RE IN A TENT HERE
SELLING GRILLED CHEESE,
AND TODAY
THEY HAVE A CHEESE EMPIRE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
HEY, EVERYBODY!
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
FOR TOM+CHEE SO FAR
HAS BEEN RETAIL SPACE.
WE'RE COMPETING
AGAINST THE BIG BOYS.
WITH BARBARA'S KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERIENCE IN REAL ESTATE,
SHE'S REALLY HELPED
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD 3 LOCATIONS
AND 70 EMPLOYEES.
WE NOW HAVE 19 LOCATIONS
AND OVER 500 EMPLOYEES
WORKING FOR US.
WE'VE RECEIVED
OVER 25,000 FRANCHISE REQUESTS.
SOON, YOU'LL BE ABLE TO FIND
TOM+CHEE IN ALL 50 STATES
AND IN COUNTRIES LIKE CANADA
AND MEXICO AND IRELAND,
UNITED ARAB EMIRATES --
PRETTY MUCH EVERYWHERE.
JOB WELL DONE.
AS A SHARK, THIS IS WHAT
I DREAM ABOUT GETTING.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
EVERY DAY.
THIS IS JUST AN AMAZING
AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY.
WE STARTED WITH AN IDEA
AND $2,400.
WE'RE GROWING THIS
INTO A MULTINATIONAL BRAND.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE
OUR GRILLED CHEESE
AND ALL THOSE SMILES
AROUND THE WORLD.
CHEESE!
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A PRODUCT
TO ENSURE YOUR BED IS ALWAYS
AT THE RIGHT TEMPERATURE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MARK ARAMLI.
I'M FROM THE BEAUTIFUL CITY
OF NEWPORT, RHODE ISLAND.
MY COMPANY IS BEDJET,
AND I'M SEEKING $250,000
FOR 10% OF THE COMPANY.
IN THE WINTERTIME,
NEVER GET
INTO ANOTHER CHILLY BED
WITH COLD FEET EVER AGAIN.
THE BEDJET IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
ULTRA-RAPID AND AFFORDABLE
COOLING, HEATING,
AND CLIMATE-CONTROL SYSTEM
DESIGNED JUST FOR OUR BEDS
AT HOME.
SIMPLY PLACE THE BASE UNIT
UNDER THE BED,
PUT THE NOZZLE
INTO YOUR BEDDING.
WE GIVE YOUR BEDDING
THAT LUXURIOUS, HOT-TOWEL,
JUST-OUT-OF-THE-DRYER FEEL
IN ONLY THREE MINUTES
FROM THE TOUCH OF A REMOTE.
REMOTE CONTROLS INCLUDE
OUR INTELLIGENT SMARTPHONE APP.
YOU CAN EVEN PROGRAM
A BEDJET ALARM
TO WAKE YOU UP IN THE MORNING
WITH A COOL BLAST OF AIR.
AH.
NOW, THE BEDJET
PAYS FOR ITSELF.
WHY HEAT OR COOL THE WHOLE HOUSE
OR EVEN BEDROOM AT NIGHT
WHEN ALL THAT MATTERS
FOR THOSE EIGHT HOURS
IS THE TEMPERATURE
BETWEEN THE SHEETS.
SHARKS, THAT'S THE BEDJET.
IF ANY OF YOU STILL HAVE
COLD FEET ON JOINING THE TEAM
AFTER WHAT YOU'VE HEARD,
THAT'S OKAY.
WE'LL WARM THEM UP
RIGHT OVER HERE.
CAN WE TRY IT?
YES.
MARK, HOW MUCH NOISE
DOES IT MAKE?
IT'S QUIETER
THAN ANY FAN.
THAN ANY ROOM AIR CONDITIONER.
OH! I'M GETTING IN BED
WITH MARK.
DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT IT.
IT'S ABOUT
THE SAME LEVEL...
WHAT DO YOU MEAN
"DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT IT?"
...OF YOUR HOUSEHOLD
HVAC REGISTER.
MOVE OVER, BUDDY.
WOW. IS THAT A WATER MATTRESS
YOU HAVE THERE?
NO.
UH, WE ARE JUST SENDING AIR
INTO THE BED
SO IT GIVES US
A LITTLE PUFFING.
WAIT.
THERE'S MORE.
50% OF COUPLES HAVE DIFFERENT
SLEEP-TEMPERATURE PREFERENCES.
HE LIKES IT HOT,
SHE LIKES IT COOL.
THERE'S ALWAYS A FIGHT
OVER THE THERMOSTAT.
THE BEDJET
HAS DUAL-ZONE CAPABILITY.
WHAT'S IT LIKE, LORI?
MY -- MY SIDE IS HOT.
I FEEL HOT AIR. RIGHT?
YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S COOL.
I MEAN,
IT FEELS GOOD ON MY FEET.
BUT THE QUESTION IS,
HOW DO YOU HOOK IT UP?
WE HAVE A NOZZLE HERE.
IF WE'RE GONNA DO DUAL ZONE,
WE PLUG IT INTO THIS.
SO, LIKE, THERE'S
A SPECIAL SHEET, RIGHT?
SO YOU PUT A SPECIAL SHEET THERE
THAT HAS THE HOLE AT THE BOTTOM?
ONLY FOR DUAL ZONE.
IF IT'S SINGLE ZONE,
RIGHT, JUST ONE --
SINGLE ZONE,
WE JUST HAVE THIS LITTLE GUY,
AND YOU'VE GOT THE SHEET
THROWN OVER HIM,
AND HE'S SENDING --
OKAY, SO THAT JUST POPS
ON THE EDGE OF THE BED,
AND IT JUST BLOWS OUT
COLD OR HOT AIR.
YOU GOT IT.
SO THAT KEEPS IT SIMPLE.
BUT ALSO, TOO,
IS THERE TWO DIFFERENT,
UM, ATTACHMENT HOSES?
THERE'S TWO MACHINES,
SO YOU'VE GOT ANOTHER ONE
INSTALLED
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
Corcoran: YOU SET A TIMER
SO YOU COULD COOL IT DOWN
FOR 10 MINUTES,
AND IT TURNS ITSELF OFF.
YEAH.
SO, WE HAVE
AUTO-SHUTOFF TIMERS
WHICH ARE VARIABLE,
DEPENDING ON WHETHER
YOU'RE HEATING OR COOLING.
PROVE TO ME
THE MARKET CARES.
YEAH, LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE ECONOMICS.
GIVE US YOUR SALES.
OKAY, WE ARE GOING
INTO PRODUCTION IN SIX WEEKS.
OH, THERE ARE NO SALES.
HOW'D YOU COME UP
WITH THIS?
I USED TO BE AN ENGINEER
ON THE NASA SPACE-SUIT PROGRAM.
OH, WOW.
AND I WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SOME OF THE COOLING
AND HEATING
AND CLIMATE-CONTROL SYSTEMS
OF THE SUIT.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE?
UH, $98.
UH, WE HAVE A, UH,
MARKET TEST
THAT WE DID VIA KICKSTARTER.
WE SOLD MORE THAN $50,000
WORTH OF PRODUCT.
WHAT WAS THE, UM,
PRICE PER UNIT?
UH, THE RETAIL PRICE FOR THIS
IS GONNA BE $499.
O'Leary: OHH!
WOW!
THAT'S MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN A MATTRESS.
HOUSTON, WE GOT A PROBLEM.
LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED
SINCE WE STARTED SELLING,
OKAY?
OKAY.
WE HAD OUR FIRST TRADE SHOW
IN LAS VEGAS,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
TRADE SHOWS
FOR THE SLEEP-PRODUCT
AND BEDDING INDUSTRY.
DURING THE SHOW,
SOMETHING MAGIC HAPPENED.
EVERY SINGLE MAJOR PLAYER
IN THE BEDDING INDUSTRY
CAME TO US AND SAID,
"WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THIS.
"WE WANT THIS.
"WE HAVE BUYER SAMPLE REQUESTS
WITH INTENT
TO PUT INTO THE MARKET
FROM MATTRESS FIRM."
MARK, THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
THESE ARE THE MATTRESS
MANUFACTURERS, OKAY?
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW
IS WHEN THE CONSUMER
WALKS UP TO THAT MACHINE
AND THEY SEE IT'S $500,
THEY SAY,
"WOW, I CAN GET A BRAND-NEW BED
FOR THAT PRICE."
I THINK THE PRICE
IS NUTS.
AT THE LAS VEGAS SHOW, OKAY,
WE HAVE NOW SIGNED UP RETAILERS
WHO ARE GETTING SAMPLES...
WHO DO YOU HAVE?
...AND WHO WANT TO PUT THIS
INTO THE MARKET.
NAME THE NAME.
SIT 'N SLEEP.
YOU WILL NEVER SELL THIS DEVICE
FOR $499.
IT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
WHY DON'T WE HEAR...
NEVER, NEVER, NEVER.
...WHAT THOSE MATTRESS
MANUFACTURERS SAID?
MR. WONDERFUL --
NOT A CHANCE IN HELL.
THE DEVIL HIMSELF
WON'T PAY YOU FOR THAT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ORDERS
AT THAT PRICE POINT?
WE HAVE A P.O.
FOR $1.1 MILLION.
REALLY?
FROM WHO?
THAT CAME IN, UH,
JUST LAST WEEK, OKAY?
THIS IS THE LARGEST
MATTRESS MANUFACTURER
AND OLDEST MANUFACTURER
IN AUSTRALIA.
WHO?
A.H. BEARD.
IT'S IMPRESSIVE.
Cuban: SO, WHAT'S
THE SECRET SAUCE IN THE DEVICE?
SO, WHAT SEPARATES US FROM
EVERYONE WHO'S COME BEFORE --
WE ARE THE ONLY PRODUCT
THAT IS ULTRA-RAPID, OKAY?
EVERY OTHER PRODUCT --
OKAY, NO, NO, WAIT.
BEFORE YOU GO AND PITCH ME,
RIGHT,
I ASKED A QUESTION.
'CAUSE WHAT I WANT
IS A TECHNICAL ANSWER.
I WANT
A TECHNICAL ANSWER
ON WHY THAT'S BETTER
OR DIFFERENT
OR WHATEVER YOU THINK
YOUR SECRET SAUCE IS
IN THE DEVICE.
OKAY, THERE'S NO PRODUCT
IN THE WORLD
THAT WILL HEAT
A KING-SIZE BED
TO FEEL LIKE THE SHEETS CAME OUT
OF THE DRYER IN THREE MINUTES.
AND WHAT ALLOWS
THAT TO HAPPEN?
AGAIN, I ASKED --
I DIDN'T ASK FOR THE PITCH.
WE'RE THE ONLY PRODUCT
THAT USES DIRECT CONVECTION AIR
INTO THE BED TO COOL YOU
AND HEAT YOU.
AND NOW --
SO YOU'RE LIKE A CONVECTION OVEN
THAT JUST TAKES THE OUTPUT
AND JUST BLOWS IT IN
UNDERNEATH THE SHEETS.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY
YOU CAN SEND
1,500 WATTS OF POWER
INTO A BED SAFELY.
MARK, YOU HAD MATTRESS
MANUFACTURERS.
THAT, TO ME,
IS THE BIGGER KAHUNA.
WHY?
NO, IT ISN'T.
MARK, WHAT DID THEY SAY TO YOU
THEY WANTED TO DO?
DID THEY SAY,
"WE WANT TO HAVE MEETINGS
WITH YOU LATER"?
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF THEM
TALKING TO YOU?
SO, SLEEP TEMPERATURE
AND SLEEP SCIENCE
IS MORE AND MORE IDENTIFYING,
UH, SLEEPING TEMPERATURE
AS HAVING A DEEP IMPACT
ON RESTFUL SLEEP.
O'Leary: LISTEN, LISTEN.
LOOK, THAT'S GREAT,
BUT I CAN SEE
MR. AND MRS. SCHLEBINSKI
WALKING IN TO BUY
A NEW MATTRESS,
AND MRS. SCHLEBINSKI
SAYS TO MR. SCHLEBINSKI,
"HONEY,
WHAT'S THAT BEDJET THERE?"
AND HE SAYS, "WOW, IT SAYS
IT HEATS OR COOLS OUR BED."
AND SHE SAYS,
"HONEY, LET'S GET IT."
AND HE SAYS,
"HOW MUCH IS IT?"
AND HE GOES, "$500!"
THEY BOTH A HEART ATTACK
AND THEY LEAVE.
DO THEY?
THERE'S 3--
I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN CAN I FIND OUT?
THERE ARE 300 MILLION BEDROOMS
IN AMERICA.
I GET ALL THAT.
NO, YOU DON'T.
THE MARKET'S SO BIG.
MY COST OF GOODS SOLD...
I WANT TO BACK
TO WHAT I ASKED YOU.
MARK, MARK, IGNORE HIM.
...IS AT 1,000 UNITS PER LOT.
MARK, IGNORE HIM.
YOU ARE GOING TO FAIL.
YOU'VE OVERPRICED IT
BECAUSE YOU'RE A PIG.
QUIET!
OHH. OY VEY.
WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THE MATTRESS
MANUFACTURERS --
MARK,
I HAVE A SIMPLE QUESTION.
MARK, IF YOU DON'T LISTEN TO ME,
I'M GOING OUT.
WHY DID YOU MAKE THIS PRODUCT?
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION.
I'M OUT.
MARK, IF YOU DON'T LISTEN TO ME,
I'M GOING OUT.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION.
I'M OUT.
'CAUSE YOU DON'T BELIEVE
YOU CAN SELL ANY.
NO, I ASKED HIM FIVE TIMES
TO ANSWER MY QUESTION,
HE IGNORED ME,
AND NOW I'M OUT.
I-I'M VERY, VERY SORRY, LORI.
SORRY.
IT'S -- IT'S HARD TO KEEP UP
WITH ALL THE QUESTIONS.
I GET IT,
BUT I WAS SHOUTING.
COULD YOU PLEASE
ASK THE QUESTION AGAIN?
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER IT.
NO.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
THE PATH FORWARD IS FOR THIS.
WE BELIEVE MARKET ENTRY FOR THIS
IS AN ASSISTED SALE.
IT NEEDS TO BE SOLD
WHERE PEOPLE BUY MATTRESSES,
SO THERE IS A PREMIUM MARKET
OUT THERE THAT IS MASSIVE.
Cuban: MARK, I THINK
IT'S A COOL PRODUCT, RIGHT?
WHAT I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
IS THAT,
WHEN I ASKED
ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY,
YOU KEPT ON SELLING.
I JUST DON'T LIKE THE VIBE.
I JUST DON'T THINK YOU HAVE ALL
THE PIECES YET TO GO FORWARD,
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
MARK,
YOU MENTIONED, CLEARLY,
THAT THIS IS INTENDED TARGETED
TO THE PREMIUM-MATTRESS BUYER.
BEYOND PREMIUM.
THAT 25% --
BUT THAT'S YOUR SWEET SPOT,
RIGHT?
HERE'S MY OBJECTION TO IT.
MOST OF THE PREMIUM BUYERS TODAY
ARE NOT BUYING THIS STYLE BED.
THE UPHOLSTERED BED
THAT ALMOST HITS THE FLOOR
IS THE MOST COMMONLY
SOLD BED TODAY.
MY BED WOULDN'T FIT THAT
UNDER THERE
BECAUSE I HAVE
A LOVELY UPHOLSTERED BED.
I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA SELL WELL HERE.
I WISH I BELIEVED YOU,
BUT I DON'T. I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
I SEE CATASTROPHE.
I SEE DISASTER.
I SEE BLACK CLOUDS,
DEVASTATION, TOTAL COLLAPSE.
HERE'S WHAT
IT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE.
YOU'RE GONNA SHIP OUT
A COUPLE OF MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF INVENTORY,
TRY AND SELL IT AT $499
AT SPECIALTY-MATTRESS STORES.
IT'S GONNA SIT THERE.
IT'S NOT GONNA TURN.
THE NIGHT STAFF
ARE GONNA TRY AND USE IT
TO ACTUALLY WASH
THE CARPETS.
THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS.
[ LAUGHS ]
THE PRODUCT IS DEAD ALREADY.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Cuban: [ LAUGHS ]
WHY WOULD YOU THANK HIM
FOR THAT?
MARK, I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH YOUR PRICE POINT.
I THINK THE, UH --
THE MACHINERY'S REMARKABLE.
I MEAN, I LOVE MACHINERY.
I LOVE MECHANICAL STUFF.
HERE'S WHERE IT FELL APART
FOR ME, THOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
YOU'RE SPENDING TOO MUCH TIME
WITH, UH,
MATTRESS SALESPEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, MARK IS RIGHT.
WHENEVER YOU WERE ASKED
A QUESTION,
YOU WENT INTO, UH...
SALES MODE.
...COLORING IT.
AND YOU WENT
INTO SALES MODE.
I LIKE THE SIZZLE,
BUT I WANT TO GET
RIGHT INTO THE STEAK,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU WORKED
AT NASA AS AN ENGINEER.
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY,
SOMEBODY TURNED YOU.
I THINK I WANTED MORE.
I DIDN'T GET MORE.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
LORI, CAN I ASK YOU,
UM, WHAT YOUR OBJECTION WAS?
WAS IT THAT I DIDN'T GET
TO YOUR QUESTION FAST ENOUGH,
OR IS IT THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF THE BUSINESS AND THE PRODUCT?
MARK, I ASKED YOU A QUESTION.
YOU DIDN'T ANSWER IT.
THEY STARTED TO TALK.
YOU STARTED TO TURN TO THEM.
SO I STARTED TO SHOUT TO YOU
MY QUESTION --
"WHOA! HEY! OVER HERE!
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT?"
YOU TURNED DOWN THERE SOMEWHERE
TO DO SOMETHING ELSE.
I SAID,
"HELLO? ANSWER ME."
WELL, LORI, WHY DON'T YOU
GET OVER IT 'CAUSE --
WAIT, WAIT.
NO, I'M NOT GONNA GET OVER IT.
IF YOU VALUED ME,
YOU WOULD'VE ANSWERED BACK
MY QUESTIONS.
SEND HER A LOVE LETTER.
AND YOU WOULD'VE SAID,
"I'LL ANSWER YOU GUYS
IN A MINUTE."
BARBARA, KNOCK IT OFF.
I THINK SHE'S --
SHE'S MAKING A GOOD POINT.
...IF IT WAS IMPORTANT.
SO I FEEL LIKE THAT'S NOT
THE RIGHT PARTNER FOR ME.
I'M REALLY SORRY
FOR THAT, LORI.
Corcoran: BUT, LORI, EVERYONE
WAS SHOUTING HIM AT ONCE.
AND IN FACT,
WHEN I CAME OUT HERE, I THOUGHT
YOU WERE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT SHARKS FOR THIS.
MARK, ARE YOU STILL HERE?
SO, CAN I GO THROUGH A LIST
OF, UH, RETAILERS?
I THINK WE'RE ALL OUT.
WE'RE ALL OUT, MARK.
YOU HAD YOUR SHOT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
IT'S A TOUGH CROWD IN THERE.
I'M GONNA PROVE KEVIN WRONG.
THIS PRODUCT IS GONNA BE HUGE.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE IT IN RETAILERS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY,
AND I'M GONNA BE HAPPY
TO BE THAT BIG DEAL
THAT GOT AWAY FROM THE TANK.